evitar que afganistán sea una amenaza
para la estabilidad regional este fue el
tema principal de la reunión de los
países vecinos celebrada en moscú rusia
china pakistán o india teme que las
tensiones tras la llegada del grupo
talibán al poder afecte a sus naciones
mientras que los talibanes reiteraron su
pedido de reconocimiento oficial a la
comunidad internacional
si el nuevo gobierno no es reconocido y
apoyado los grupos que perturban la
seguridad naturalmente se fortalecerán
también
no permitiremos que nadie ni ningún
grupo se acabe la seguridad del pueblo
afgano de los vecinos de afganistán y de
los países de la región y fuera de ella
en el
ambiente ante todo para aumentar el
traje
el kremlin lideró los pedidos para
proporcionar ayuda internacional a kabul
e intentar frenar el inminente colapso
económico porque la semana pasada el
mandatario ruso vladimir putin dijo que
no había que apresurarse a reconocer
oficialmente al gobierno talibán la
delegación rusa alegó que espera el
respeto a los derechos humanos básicos
por parte de los fundamentalistas y la
lucha contra el terrorismo y el
narcotráfico haciéndose eco de las
preocupaciones de los gobiernos de todo
el mundo como parte de las
conversaciones en moscú las diez
naciones participantes pidieron a
naciones unidas que celebre una
conferencia internacional para asegurar
la ayuda económica al país
uno de los momentos clave es el
llamamiento de todos los participantes
en el formato de moscú a la onu para que
celebre una conferencia internacional de
donantes con el fin de proporcionar
ayuda socioeconómica al desarrollo de
afganistán tras el conflicto
la mayoría de gobiernos del mundo entre
ellos eeuu o rusia no reconocen al nuevo
ejecutivo talibán y han congelado la
entrega de ayuda humanitaria por falta
de garantías de respeto de los derechos
humanos de la población afgana sin un
avance notable en este asunto